[Musique]
Marie-Pierre on le dit depuis le début
de l'émission à quel point
l'intelligence artificielle bouleverse
nos vies dans le moindre détail de notre
quotidien et un peu plus parce que même
quand on pense à la mort il y a de
l'intelligence artificielle oui on peut
dire que quel va changer notre mort un
peu comme elle change des gens un peu
nos vies parce qu'elle nous fait une
promesse qui est quand même assez
spectaculaire la promesse de
l'immortalité c'est pas rien c'est un
vieux rêve de l'humanité
plus grosse promesse de la science nous
tripatouiller les gènes pour nous rendre
immortel nous cloner pour nous rendre
immortel nous entreposer dans de l'azote
liquide à moins 96 degrés à notre décès
pour nous rendre immortel et là avec
l'intelligence artificielle on peut dire
qu'on est plus près du but que jamais
même si cette immortalité là on s'entend
elle est totalement illusoire pour
l'instant mais à quoi elle ressemble ré
cette réalité cette immortalité qui
ressemblerait on a même pas besoin de
parler aux conditionnel parce que ça se
fait pas mal déjà on parle c'est pas
encore très déployé mais la technologie
existe on parle en gros de créer des
robots conversationnels donc les fameux
chatbot à l'image d'une personne qui est
décédée pour éventuellement pouvoir
avoir des discussions avec elle après
son décès ok donc la personne décédée
sous les traits du robot conversationnel
on peut rajouter différentes
possibilités jusqu'à avoir une
représentation visuelle mais donc par
exemple Microsoft a annoncé en juin
dernier qu'ils avaient déposé un brevet
pour justement un logiciel qui promet de
en quelque sorte réincarner une personne
décédée en son choix virtuel il y a
aussi Amazon qui est en train de
développer avec Alexa son assistante
virtuelle
en gros ce qu'on pourrait lui faire
faire c'est de lui faire lire une
histoire avec la voix de n'importe qui
ces dernières semaines à l'émission
C'est une technologie qui a priori
servait pas à faire parler une personne
décédée mais là ça se développe avec de
plus en plus de ça reproduit de plus en
plus fidèlement la voix des personnes
exactement et dans la démo qu'on pouvait
voir c'était une grand maman qui lisait
une histoire à son petit-fils bon a
priori c'est ça qui est ça une histoire
lue par une grand-mère peut-être décédée
mais on imagine jusqu'où tout ça
pourrait aller éventuellement jusqu'à
avoir une conversation avec grand-maman
qui est au ciel
si on ajoute le visuel on a
littéralement on peut pratiquement
l'avoir devant soi donc on imagine
facilement jusqu'où tout ça peut aller
puis ça fait un petit peu peur
pour ce visualiser comme il faut le
géniché une vidéo qui est vraiment très
troublante
c'est un documentaire coréen qui
s'appelle meeting you et on peut voir
bon c'est une maman dont la petite fille
est morte à l'âge de 7 ans d'une maladie
puis elle est morte de façon très très
soudaine quelque chose comme une semaine
après le diagnostic donc cette mer là ça
voulait un peu de pas avoir pu faire ses
adieux à sa fille comme elle aurait
souhaité le faire et donc l'équipe de ce
documentaire là a organisé une rencontre
virtuelle entre la mère et sa fille
décédée c'est très difficile à regarder
puis on s'entend là ça a été fait en
2020 donc d'un point de vue strictement
technologique ça fait une éternité
voilà donc le tout le niveau réaliste
tout ça c'est pas du tout au point mais
quand même ça donne un aperçu de quoi
tout ça peut ressembler puis cette femme
là a dit que ça l'a quand même aidé à
pouvoir dire une dernière fois au revoir
à sa fille
tu nous parles d'exemple qui date quand
même de 2020 est-ce qu'il y en a des
plus récents qui un vont dans le même
sens avec un plus grand raffinement
on a vraiment l'embarras du choix un qui
avait fait beaucoup parler c'est celui
d'un jeune homme dont l'amoureuse était
décédé elle s'appelait Jessica j'ai
utilisé une technologie qui s'appelle
gipiti tree donc en quelque sorte
l'ancêtre de Tchad Jupiter qui fait
énormément jaser lui aussi ces temps-ci
et donc créer une Jessica virtuelle
qu'il a alimenté avec des publications
qu'elle avait fait sur les réseaux
sociaux des discussions privées entre
les deux aussi donc quand même pas mal
d'informations à son sujet et il a
commencé à clavarder avec cette fausse
coller c'est seulement du texte et ils
ont passé des heures à discuter et ce
qu'ils disaient c'est que vraiment cette
Jessica virtuelle disait le genre de
choses que la vraie Jessica de la même
façon
qu'elle les aurait dites donc il passait
beaucoup beaucoup de temps parler avec
elle et ce programme-là était conçu de
telle sorte que un peu comme dans la
vraie vie il y a une longévité
déterminée donc par exemple on se le
fait dire quand a été rendu à 55 % là il
a commencé à se poser des questions à
plus trop vouloir parler longtemps avec
elle parce que il voulait pas que ça
finisse qu'elle finisse par mourir parce
que à 20% là c'était fait pour que
l'avatar commence à être un peu confus
c'est vraiment comme une mort numérique
après la mort réelle et lui s'est dit
que bon il était prêt à la laisser aller
ce qu'il a fait il s'est dit il va pas
créer d'autres Jessica apparemment que
ça l'aidait dans son processus de deuil
mais on voit tout de suite le potentiel
de dérive à partir du moment où on veut
soutirer toujours plus d'argent à la
personne qui voudrait garder
perpétuellement envie la personne qu'il
attend aimer donc il y a quelque chose
là encore d'un petit peu
échec là-dedans on s'entend aussi que
pour que ça fonctionne il faut avoir
quand même laisser quelques traces
numériques de son vivant c'est pas tout
le monde qui enlève des traces
de créer quelque chose comme ça à partir
d'un jeune Millenial qui publie toujours
sur les réseaux sociaux qui utilisent
beaucoup les messages textes que par
exemple avec des gens qui sont morts
depuis plusieurs années puis qui ont à
peu près laissé aucune trace numérique
mais lorsqu'on veut faire c'est de nous
inciter à prendre soi-même les devants
de notre vivant et il y a différents
services qui permettent de le faire par
exemple l'application here after ça a
été inventé par un homme qui s'était
lui-même créé son propre dadbot son père
décédé d'un cancer un peu la même genre
d'histoire avec lequel ils étaient mis à
discuter de cette façon là il y a créé
son application et c'est vraiment ça le
principe quand on est vivant on doit
même répondre à un maximum de questions
fournir le plus d'informations possibles
pour se créer un genre de jumeaux
virtuel qui va survivre à notre décès et
avec lequel nos proches vont pouvoir
continuer à discuter ensuite quand on
parle de deuil c'est un processus qui
est complexe qui est difficile pour bien
des gens dans quelle mesure
l'intelligence artificielle peut nous
aider sur le plan thérapeutique est-ce
que les spécialistes les experts
Marie-Pierre se sont prononcés là-dessus
j'ai animé une table ronde sur ce sujet
là en novembre dernier au Musée de la
civilisation on avait différents
spécialistes qui échangeaient sur le
sujet dont une spécialiste du deuil
l'anthropologue Luce des aulniers et ce
qu'elle nous disait en très résumé c'est
que ce genre de technologie là nous
garde River dans le passé
c'est comme si sa figeait le deuil en
quelque sorte et elle disait aussi que
toutes les recherches qui se sont
penchées là-dessus concluaient que
c'était un poison c'est le
même si sur le coup ça peut sembler
faire du bien là il y a des questions
légales qui se posent est-ce qu'on peut
dans quelle mesure on peut entreposer
entre guillemets le parcours la vie
l'identité d'une personne de façon
illimitée
a fait le prix des acteurs
oui dans des films après leur décès je
pense entre autres à kawi-ficher qui a
interprété la princesse Leia grâce à des
hypertructages dans Star Wars
bon les questions juridiques c'est géré
étape par état aux États-Unis mais de
manière générale les
héritiers ont leur mot à dire à savoir
si oui ou non on accepte que tel acteur
puis-je jouer dans un film après son
décès c'est un peu surréaliste à dire
mais c'est ça ça Hollywood mais pour le
commun des mortels au Québec
là on peut dire qu'on est en territoire
inconnu pas très belle
tous les notaires ne sont pas des
spécialistes de l'intelligence
artificielle et de la protection des
données donc c'est vraiment ça le pour
l'instant et c'est un un flottement
générationnel pour être dire un gros
flou
et puis un autre élément qu'on ramène
beaucoup depuis le début de cette
émission c'est à quel point c'est pas
tout à fait à pointe tout seul ça ça
évolue constamment un rythme effréné il
y a des questions qui demeurent très
hypothétiques mais pas pour longtemps
Marie-Pierre on voit à quel point tout
ça progresse à la vitesse grand V c'est
on a aucun mal à croire aujourd'hui que
se réalise là qui est pas tout à fait au
point aujourd'hui il le sera dans pas
très longtemps et c'est un réflexe
tellement humain que de quand on perd
quelqu'un qu'on aime de vouloir
s'accrocher de vouloir la garder vivante
dans notre esprit que ça soit travers on
le fait de tout temps avec des photos
des écrits des vieux objets c'est normal
c'est naturel puis oui ça fait du bien
ça fait partie du processus de deuil
maintenant est-ce qu'on peut en vouloir
c'est certain que les gens vont être
tentés de
d'y aller avec un petit niveau plus en
matière de réalisme et il va falloir se
poser ces questions là à commencer
vraiment par la question fondamentale
est-ce que tout ça risque pas de nous
faire plus de mal que de bien